i'm a chalkboard person so uh we'll be
drawing up here
during the course of the session but um
what we thought when we were first
trying to talk about this
uh this program was we have 45 minutes
today we have an hour tomorrow
we thought it made more sense to break
it into two pieces
today will be basic estate planning
we'll walk you through
some of the the elementary stuff that
you should have in place
and uh and things that you definitely
want to do
and then tomorrow's advanced estate
planning we'll start walking through
some of the
additional games that can be played uh
the things that get tax attorneys
excited
and uh and so if if today is too basic
for you
feel free to say i want to get out in
the sunshine take off
and come back tomorrow for the more
advanced material
the we i wanted to put it together
in a form that would be something of a
flow chart for you
so you should walk through that's why
we've passed out
these materials which will be uh the
equivalent of slides but i'm going to
draw them because i think they sometimes
make more sense as you see them develop
on the screen but there are multiple uh
enhancements of the basic design
and what is sort of standard planning uh
for any estate planning couple who goes
into this
uh material and so let me
plunge in and start with
the first issue which is what are these
instruments that you should have and
the traditional has been the will
everyone knows you write a will well
you really don't want to write just a
will anymore
um the primary estate planning device is
the revocable trust or the living trust
you've heard this on the advertisements
come to our seminar learn about
revocable trust save taxes and so forth
and it really is the device of choice
and in california
for those of you are from this state
absolutely
and there's a there's an expense reason
involved
i 15 years ago i told clients
write a will write a revocable trust
there's a trade-off
you spend more time and expense today
writing the trust
and transferring assets into the trust
and the idea is to save money in the
long run
you save money in the probate and
administrative
costs the legal fees and court costs
when someone becomes incompetent or dies
well that's a
sometimes a long way off into the future
discounted present value of those
savings
are computable in some sense and you
weighted against the
um the the savings that uh the costs
that are involved now and during the
revolt with us it was a wash most of the
time
well our california legislature and our
congress changed that
california used to have an estate tax
it was a piece of the federal tax so if
there was a federal tax due
california got a portion of it called
the state death tax credit
and california repealed its inheritance
tax and created
what they called a pickup tax they said
our estate tax is whatever
you get when you have a state death tax
credit so just send us the federal
return and a check
for whatever is due and so the total tax
was always the same it's just a piece of
it went to california
in 2001 when they passed the major tax
change
they repealed the state death tax credit
and turned it into a deduction and then
phased
out the credit over several years
the california rule was established by a
statewide
vote so it couldn't be changed by
the legislature alone the result was
we no longer have a california estate
tax it's disappeared
along with the money which now goes to
washington and so the legislature said
gee
this is a problem we've got to try to
collect some of this money
so the first issue is well can we pass
a another estate tax in california and
of course
the answer to that is not a chance and
so they raised the filing fees
for probate and they made it a
percentage of the gross
assets so initially traditionally you
would
pay maybe 100 to 150 dollars to file a
will for probate
now it's two tenths of one percent of
the gross
assets it's a disguised estate tax
and they passed it and they made it i
thought they i guess they thought they
were making it
uh judgment proof because they made sure
that the funds went to the judges
funds and so uh
yeah i told people i thought it was a
disguised estate tax that was a
violation of the statewide vote and
probably could be challenged
and if you get a large enough estate
there'll be enough money at stake
well this week for the first time i got
an email where they have found a class
action lawyer
a law firm and they're looking for a
lead plaintiff
to take on this uh this fee that has
been imposed
and you may very well see this
overturned i think uh
if they may have to go into federal
court state court judges may not agree
but uh i think we may see this change
but in the meantime
the cost of simply filing the will for
probate
far exceeds the art marginal additional
cost of doing a revocable trust
so first item on your list is
the document you want is the revocable
trust
this is where you write your estate plan
you still have a will
as you'll see to back it up but this is
really the instrument everybody uses now
especially in california
and i recommend it to everyone sort of
no matter how large the estate
or how young the clients this is the way
to go
saves you administrative time saves you
legal fees saves you court costs
saves you these filing fees saves you
referee fees
it goes on and on and it's really the
right way to go
the trick is what you write in this and
that's
the heart of what we're going to be
talking about today
you begin
with the estate tax i tell clients there
are actually
five different taxes you have to worry
about when you do planning
income tax gift tax
estate tax generation skipping tax
and property tax and they are not
coordinated
so you can trip over one while you're
trying to work with another you have to
go through
any action you take you've got to flip
through all five taxes to make sure
you've got it
uh done correctly without some mistake
but the estate tax is really the main
one and
it's a relatively simple tax if you go
to diagram
two
this is for a single person
for estate tax purposes the irs really
likes you
because you're taxed the worst of
everyone
the way the tax works is you you do it
it's a it is really simple
add up the fair market value of
everything you own
clothing jewelry furniture cash
securities
real estate iras 401ks
life insurance proceeds you literally
add up everything
fair market value subtract out the debts
and you get a net worth
that's my rectangular box
there is a piece of that that is free of
estate tax
no matter who you give it to that's what
i call the tax exempt
portion the bottom piece you start
counting from the bottom up
today that exempt portion is two million
dollars
but it's changing it's on a roller
coaster
for the next two and a half years it's
two million dollars
in 2009 it goes to three and a half
million dollars
in 2010 that's the year of the so-called
repeal
it's unlimited no matter how much you
have no estate tax
and in 2011 it comes back
down to where it was in 2001 which is
one million
up and then back down if your estate is
over
one million dollars then you have to
file a return
and you may or may not have a tax
depending on what you do
if you're under a million dollars and
you're single you don't have an estate
tax problem
you have other issues to deal with who
you give it to who's going to be in
charge
which the revocable trust handles
but the estate tax is not a problem for
you
and it's not a california estate tax
either because that's gone
so when you're looking at the planning
most of the state planning is tax
oriented but there's a whole group of
people who fall into the under the tax
exempt limit
who do estate planning for other
purposes
what if you're over that well this is
where
you really get hammered the tax rate
since i find it hard to multiply by
either 46 percent or 55
i tell people it's basically half of
what's left
goes to the government um it's a
round numbers fifty percent of state tax
right now it's 46.
it's going to drop down to 45 and then
in 2011
it bounces back to the old rates which
range up to 55 percent
highest rates in the code so when you
get into the estate tax
range it's brutal it is really painful
one of the questions that comes up is
gee um
bob aren't they going to fix this
there was uh there was i was over
listening to the questions on jim
patel's
program and there was a lady at the end
who was suggesting well gee
don't do you think you ought to bring in
maybe psychologists and sociologists to
uh to assist in your programs in these
developing countries and maybe
politicians and there was this groan
from the audience they i think our
congress is held in low esteem at this
time
and part of it certainly in the estate
planning community we looked at this
thing in 2001 and we said well
this is clearly a temporary bridge they
won't leave this mess alone they'll fix
it
that was five years ago i look at it now
and i think there's a good chance we
will have continue to have gridlock on
this thing
and part of the reasoning is there's an
incentive for both parties
not to negotiate this summer
the big effort to try and come up with a
compromise
and the republicans said we'll give you
minimum wage
you give us significant reduction of
estate tax 5 million
exemption and lower brackets 15 30
percent
and the democrats said we'll give you
your repeal but we get minimum wage so
they had an
extra incentive for both parties they
got something they wanted but they had
to compromise and give something to the
other side
and they couldn't get the votes they
couldn't bring it together
for the democrats they look at it and
say you know if we wait till 2011
we lose one year's estate tax
but then we're back into a bargaining
position that was the same
as in 2001 we
have a stronger position to negotiate
what we want we'll either get some other
trade-off
if we give them a reduction in state tax
or something else
but we're in a stronger bargaining
position the republicans look at it and
they say
you know we've carried the flag
we got a one-year repeal we've done our
best on this
we can go to our our groups who support
this and say
we've we've tried hard it's those
democrats who are stopping us
and in the meantime they pick up an
extra 40 or 50 billion a year
which is really handy in congress at
least at this time
and so i look at this i say why what
what is it that's going to move them to
compromise i think you have to
realistically
look at the statute as it's currently
written and realize
it may be there and since
most of you that i see look in pretty
good shape
you're probably going to make it to
2011. so you know there's this very
small window of 2010
that you make it past and you're okay
but then you're into the higher tax
um if they do change it i mean they've
done all kinds of
of things back there
i don't know that it'll come out to
something sensible
it struck me that getting rid of the
estate tax for the great bulk of people
so they don't have to spend money on
estate planning attorneys and so forth
it's good social policy
notwithstanding the loss of income that
goes with it
but the the number of people who are
affected by this tax
is really much larger than the number
who end up paying it
because they've got to hire the planners
the attorneys the accountants the
investment advisors
to try to get themselves out of this tax
or reduce it so it goes much beyond the
one-half of one percent who end up
paying any tax on this thing
it affects you know kind of a broad
portion of society and it really
requires a lot of planning
and we're going to tell you a little bit
some of that planning that you get to do
so that diagram number two gives you the
idea if you're a single person
one two one way to get rid of the tax
though that's really nice
and this is a short word from our
sponsor uh
charitable giving is deductible
anything off the top comes down
and reduces your estate tax now there's
a cost to the other beneficiaries
but it's only 50 cents on the dollar so
uh so there are really admirable
institutions out there whose names you
can probably think of
and uh and you can so if you're a single
person and you're looking to reduce the
estate tax obviously charitable giving
is
one of the ways to go and i'm gonna
mention one other device that's really
it's not just a fifty percent uh cost
saving it's 75 cents
that doesn't go to the government and
we'll talk about that later
now let me go to
the revocable trust and go back to
diagram one for a second
simplistic but for a typical couple or a
single person
you have a revocable trust but you still
have a will
it's what's called a pour over will
and it says the revocable trust only
works on assets where title has been
changed into our names as trustees
if it's not in our names as trustees
then it's a probate asset
and is controlled by the will so the
will says
i hope i put everything in that trust
but if i missed
and i left something out fine when you
when you're done probating it as you
will have to do
distribute it to the trust and then the
trust distributes
uh the assets according in accordance
with his terms
as a question how many of you already
have revocable trusts
shogun this is oh okay
we're way ahead on this group this is a
the you underst you've been told the
reasons for it
now what you write in this thing this is
where
i want to lay out the basic plan that
you typically have
so you start with your revocable trust
and you hold hopefully all of your
property
other than qualified plans and i'll talk
about those in a little bit
in the name of the trust while you're
alive
you run it just like you're doing now
all of you who have it
you spend the money where you want you
control it you don't even file
an income tax return for it anymore you
just report everything on your
individual return if you're still filing
an income tax return
that says everything's on my individual
return you can stop that they change the
reg on that
so now we don't have warehouses filled
with empty returns
until someone dies it just operates as a
title holding
device it's really not
visible or effective for anything other
than avoiding probate court if someone
becomes incompetent
or dies when the first spouse dies
then you split it into the two shares
that's we're starting with diagram
three and you'll see how these hopefully
flow together
well you've got the deceased spouse
their share
and you've got the surviving spouse's
share you split it now what is the
deceased spouse's share in the
survivorship
share it's for californians
we have both community property and
separate property
separate property belongs to one spouse
does not belong to the other
they control it they dispose of it
community is owned 50 50.
each owns half each disposes of half
so the deceased spouse's half is they're
separate if any
and they're half of the community and
the survivors
is their separate property and their
half of the community and what happens
on the first death
is that gets divvied up it's into shares
or at least theoretically when you do
the distributions you don't actually
split everything 50 50
you can do them non-pro rata but the
idea is
in value you've got to have two portions
and then the question is what do you do
with this piece survivors
well the traditional basic plan
is the survivor's trust
which is just an ongoing
revocable trust it's just like the
revocable trust before
it's the survivors property they're the
trustee
they can revoke and amend it they can
spend it any way they want
it's their property that gets set up
the real planning is what happens
with the deceased spouse's share
and in the basic plan you split it into
two
pieces the first piece
is everything a value all the way up to
whatever the
exempt amount is at the time of death
right now two million dollars in 2010
it's unlimited so warren buffett could
put all
40 billion over here if he wants that
year
whatever the exempt amount is
that passes free of tax
now what do you do with it well
you put it into
an irrevocable trust
typical name for this is bypass trust it
goes by the name
be trust exemption trust
credit shelter trust family trust
all these different names are just
synonyms it's an
irrevocable trust that is held for the
survivor's benefit
for their lifetime and why do you do it
because it's written so that when the
survivor dies
later on they are not
considered to own this trust
for estate tax purposes so it passes
free of estate tax on the second death
to whoever the designated beneficiaries
are
including any growth appreciation
in the assets that went into it
originally
so if you can put two million dollars in
here
when the first spouse dies and you
find google two and it's four billion
when the survivor dies the entire 4
billion goes free of estate tax it's a
wonderful little
black box tax shelter
first question is well that's fine but
what kind of benefits does the survivor
get
and this is what's great about it's
incredibly
flexible you can have all four of these
characteristics
and it still won't be subject to estate
tax
the first is the trustee
can be that surviving spouse they can be
the sole trustee of this trust
so they can manage the property invest
it
and make any trust decisions that a
trustee would make
second all of the income
can go to that spouse interest
dividends net rentals or
use of property very often
will fund this with all or a portion of
the house
and they have the right to live in it
rent free they just use it
and that's fine if it's funded with
investable type assets
all of the income can go over to the
survivor
if that's not enough
as trustee
the survivor can invade the principle of
the trust
for their own health maintenance
support and education
in their view
they're the trustee i tell people if you
can't
fit something under that call me
we'll work on it we'll find a way to fit
it under one of these headings there
actually is no tax
definition of these things it's a
webster's dictionary kind of
look up we we actually had somebody ask
well is there any tax
case that defines what these things are
and the answer is no not really
they're words of art they're in the
statute and they work
bad words are comfort you can't be
comforted
uh welfare no welfare
but if you use the right words health
maintenance support and education
you're home free you can invade the
whole thing now
who's going to complain
it's not the irs the irs says
if you leave the assets in here we do
not get to tax them
the people who complain are the folks
who come
after surviving spouse
typically ungrateful children
they say you know dad said health
maintenance support and education
mom says a ferrari
this is where the fourth power is very
important because
those kids can go to court and they can
say to the judge
tell mom to put the money back in
the fourth power this is typical of
lawyers
this is an irrevocable trust
the fourth power gives the survivor the
right to change the ending
this sounds inconsistent lawyers have no
problem holding inconsistent thoughts at
the same time
so it's the words can't be changed but
within the words
the survivor can have a special
power of appointment it's the right to
change who the beneficiaries are
to anyone in the world except their
creditors
or the creditors of their estate usually
not high on anybody's list of
beneficiaries anyway
and so when a child objects
parent says don't worry you're no longer
a beneficiary
it's all going to your sibling or the
spca or whoever you want to send it to
when you look at these four powers
you manage and invest it you get all the
income
you take out the principal if you need
it and you get to say who gets it when
you die
that's full control what else is there
so this design
is the equivalent of all to my spouse
the old
traditional plan but it has the
advantage of
no tax on second death
and that's why people do it they
wouldn't write a bypass trust many times
if they could get around this problem
but and
but they write it because they can get
the equivalent of full control
and get the tax benefit now an
interesting
aspect of the compromise that was put in
uh this summer was to give
people the right to
bequeath this exemption
so that you could hand the exemption off
to
another ben a spouse and avoid having to
set up the bypass trust
since that went down to defeat we it
hasn't been studied a whole lot
and there may be some really complex
problems that we may run into
and how we deal with that can it be
bequeathed twice
to the next one what if you have
children as beneficiary so forth
i think it probably will come up more
in those circumstances where people have
not done their planning
and this helps them save them from
having
an extra estate tax but know that that's
one of the things that was put out there
now
this is your basic plan you end up
after the first death this trust goes
away and you end up with two trusts
and the surviving spouse still controls
everything
let me take you to the next step
go to diagram four
now the survivor dies we've already
touched on part of this
this is when the irs becomes a
beneficiary
when survivor dies basically
half of everything over a million
dollars
goes to the irs that that's when they
really get their cut
it as we said at 50 it can be a huge
amount
it may be even more because
what if you have more than 2 million in
here
the excess typically
is given to that spouse as well
the reason that excess is given
is because anything passing to a spouse
who is a u.s citizen is free of estate
tax
unlimited it's like a charitable
deduction and it's called
the marital deduction so wherever this
dividing line occurs the excess
is typically given to the survivor's
trust but as you can see
that's not an elimination of tax that's
a deferral
all you've done is put it off until the
second death but still pretty good
you've had the spouses have the
availability of the entire estate during
their lifetimes
and it's only when the survivor dies
that the irs steps in
and who really bears the tax are those
ungrateful children
down here they're the ones who really
bear the tax
so most of your estate planning is
altruistic
you two don't feel the tax you're gone
it's these people who are encouraging
you to go see the estate planning
attorney
and when they when they come around and
say you know we'd like to suggest you
maybe go see the lawyer
we have some good they're looking at
this they know it's going to be
horrendous
survivor dies half of everything over a
million
goes to the kids
and this piece comes down
no tax because of the way the trust is
written
what if the children are young
or older but still financially
incompetent
we've never run into that
we're not ready to hand a whole bunch of
assets over to these kids
they're just not able to we need to
manage it for them
well that's what we call
a separate share trust it's just a
jargon term
it means whatever share is going to go
to a child doesn't go
outright it goes into a trust
the trustee manages it for them
financially competent aunt or uncle
um or friend or bank
someone other than the child
typically someone other than a sibling
too
nothing to set kids against each other
to assure family discussions of a heated
type
than having one sibling telling the
other one you can't have that
you know who are you how many of us have
heard sibling arguments
and so you often try to get an
independent third party
who maybe has the respect of the child
or at least has financial administrative
capability
and they run the thing and then the
property comes out
oh a typical scheme would be gee they
get half a
25 and half at 30.
before that the trustee could spend the
whole thing for health
maintenance support education so you get
them through school you take care of
medical problems
but they get control at designated ages
and the reason you do typically a split
is the learning process if they blow the
first
round hopefully by the time they're 30
they've gotten
a better attitude toward maintaining
capital
some clients look at it and say 25 was a
great year
30 is going to be another one i'm
looking forward to it
uh thank you mom and dad can't wait um
others
there's a maturing process that goes on
early 20s still learning about money
haven't learned how little is left after
income taxes and fica and everything
else
living expenses by 30 often
either have been in the workplace for a
while
may be married may have a family may
have a mortgage
all these things bring a different
attitude toward
what life costs and what what a capital
fund
looks like and so it's nice to spread
this out it could be any age
it's up to you um
the longest one i had gentleman was in
his 70s
his was distributed at 55 60
and 65 to his son
i think there was something else going
on there but
um but you can also look at it as gee i
you know things go wrong in life and i
don't think the personality of my child
is going to change very much
so i'm going to spread this off over a
long period of time and i'm going to
give them slices over time things like
that
it's some element of trying to make sure
that there's financial security
knowing that if it gets out into their
hands it may not be
financially well handled but it's up to
you
to look at if you have mature children
uh
you say why do we need these trust funds
they're all over 25 they all have their
mbas
we want them to manage our money we'll
give it to them right away we don't need
a separate
share trust and so depending upon age
and maturity you may or may not have
these trusts
this again standard plan
that's what diagram four is you get that
done
and you've done some very good estate
planning
you've done the equivalent of the
traditional nuclear marriage we want it
all to stay in the family
and we want to save estate taxes and
pass it on down
what if you don't have the traditional
nuclear marriage what if it's a his and
hers
marriage children by prior marriages
well the problem is
if you give all this excess to the
spouse they'll give it to their children
by their prior marriage rather than your
children by your prior marriage
and the the client says well i want to
provide for the spouse
i want to avoid estate tax but i want to
be sure
my share of the estate ends up with my
kids by my prior marriage
so congress gave us the solution
get rid of my drawing
and the jargon term
is q-tip trust stands for qualified
terminal interest property trust
everybody calls it q-tip
um those of you know
uh trademark law you have to defend your
trademark or it becomes part of the
public domain
and so when this thing was first passed
there was an advertisement in the wall
street journal
that said uh johnson johnson please
request all estate planning attorneys to
refrain from using the term q-tip
and he had to know what they were doing
it was they were able to take this card
to
this advertiser to the uh to the court
and say we tried
we really tried to defend things but
it's called a q-tip everybody calls it
that
the gist of it is when the first spouse
dies
they send the excess
to the q-tip trust which is an
irrevocable trust
they don't give it to the spouse
it's written so it qualifies for the
marital deduction so there's still no
tax on first death
it has a couple of requirements
all of the income has to go to the
survivor
and nobody else including children can
be a beneficiary while the survivor is
alive
but if you do that it qualifies for the
marital deduction
and then this spouse can say where this
goes
on second death not the survivor
and what happens then it's a little
variation
on the distribution here are the
surviving
spouses children
here are the deceased spouse's children
when the survivor dies the bypass flows
down here
the q-tip flows down here and the
survivors flows to their children
so you've been able to dispose of the
two shares of the estate
down to the people each spouse wanted to
benefit what's the bad aspect of this
well when the survivor
dies this is treated as if it's owned by
the survivor
for estate tax purposes so the estate
tax consequence
is exactly the same as an outright gift
they add these two together
and then compute the tax so
what happens
is half of the q-tip goes to the irs as
well
it's piled on top of the survivor's
estate
and the benefit is you deferred the tax
the detriment is it finally gets hit on
the second death
but that allows you in the more what is
becoming a more traditional
family the blended marriage of children
by prior marriages
to still get the same plan the same tax
planning
and the same tax benefits and that's
laid out on diagram five
the ear of the q-tip trust
and on diagram six what happens when the
second death occurs
they'll flow down two very basic
kinds of plans now q-tip
isn't always used with blended marriages
sometimes there's disagreement between
the spouses in the nuclear marriage
about either who this goes to or
at what stages
one spouse thinks the children are fine
deserve all the money right away other
spouse says not a chance
or this spouse says i want more than
just the children to benefit i've got
other beneficiaries
and this spouse says i don't agree and
this spouse the first one to die doesn't
want to take a chance that those
plans won't get implemented so this is a
control device for more than just
blended families
it can be a controlled device in nuclear
marriages where it isn't clear it's all
going to go
to either the same set of children or
the same set of beneficiaries
each spouse can still control the plan
and to the extent they want to control
it
they can play with this set
of rules this is the broadest
you can write it you don't have to write
that
spouse may say oh last person i would
put in charge of running the money
is my spouse i don't want to have them
in charge i want an independent trustee
i also don't want them making decisions
about invading principal
they will i want to protect them i will
give an independent trustee the power to
invade principle
but i don't want to give it to my spouse
because they might abuse it
it's the guru problem
the guru needs a new temple oh i know
just where to get the money
or the spouse may say look i don't want
to maintain
an elaborate lifestyle they have their
own separate property
medical emergencies fine
anything else no i'm going to limit what
you can invade principle for
and special power of appointment well
first thing i'm going to limit it only
to the family no guru
no new spouse and maybe i'm going to
limit it to a piece of the trust
i want to know that some peace goes down
the children or i'm not going to give
them any power
at all it goes down to the kids and
that's it
nobody can change it you have a dilemma
there's not a right
answer here on this the greater the
flexibility
that you build into this or this the
greater the ability of the survivor to
meet
unforeseen circumstances the bankruptcy
of the child
so if the money goes to the child it
goes to the creditors not to them
or the ipo and the child says don't send
it to me
bob's telling me to get rid of my estate
send it to the grandchildren
do it some different way things change
between first and second death
if you've got great flexibility you can
meet those change circumstances
or it might be abused and it ends up
going to the guru
the greater the certainty
the greater the risk that it won't be
appropriate when the time
comes the child we've seen this
is in drugs and if they get the money
they're going to kill themselves all
right get out of the motel shoot up and
that's it they're gone
how do we stop it how do we prevent this
money from flowing out
it's 15 years later different world from
what was written originally
and nobody can stop it it's built in
stone
so you look at that spectrum and you say
there isn't a right answer here there's
a judgment call that you make in terms
of
how much authority do i want to give the
spouse or
any other person you give the power to
to change things
how much do i want to have it written so
i know what's going to happen
knowing there are risks and benefits on
both sides and that's the hard part
part of the hard part of estate planning
that you need to go through
now let me take you one step further
this is second death property goes down
and here bear with me i'm going to skip
down to this as well
what happens when the kids die
well whichever way you do it to the two
sets of children or all to the children
to the extent they get it when they die
the irs says great give me
another round okay
i got them when the parents died i'm
going to get them when the children die
and i will have a second estate tax
at that level and what's left
comes down to the grandchildren
and in fact this works every generation
this is the irs ideal
work hard save your money and give us
half of it in the end
and do it every generation well you you
know
having generation after generation a
fourth
and eighth it whatever the estate was
gets shrunk
pretty dramatically over two or three
generations
question is there anything we can do
about that and this is where
we have another game and this is a game
i recommend
to just about everybody because it's
sort of a why not
the question is can we do something like
a bypass
trust for the children and the answer is
yes
this is what's called the generation
skipping trust
we used to play a game
like this
parent child grandchild
great grandchild
the old pattern is everybody sends it
down the line
and every generation you pay an estate
tax so you lose half
and when there's enough money and the
children are well enough off
the game we would play is hey skip
the kids you still got to pay an estate
tax but send it to
send this estate to the grandchildren
and send this estate to the great
grandchildren
you haven't avoided estate tax it's
still imposed
it's just cut in half the number of
times the irs gets its cut
so the family wealth stays together for
a longer period of time gary said that's
a loophole
we aren't getting that second tax
we said yes that's why we do it
and whenever you get smart allergy with
the irs they give you a new tax
so they gave us the generation skipping
tax
to get the equivalent of that now the
way it works is this way
at the margin the estate tax is 50
percent
you compute that first and pay it now
you're looking at the net
after tax and the irs said
that's fine and out of that 50 percent
that's left
if you try this game we'll hit you with
another 50 percent
so we get a combined 75
tax on that we're getting our second tax
well they they were vicious because they
not only got their second tax but they
got it
earlier with the estate tax they had to
wait till the child died
with the generation skipping tax they
got it when the parent died
so they got it a generation earlier
well if you figure 30 years for a
generation discounted present value of
30 years of money
it's a hundred percent it's the only
confiscatory tax
in the code and it's disguised it's
really slick
i mean you gotta give them a lot of
credit for coming up with a hundred
percent tax
and not telling us
why do i tell you this because
the reason we pay congress so much money
is
to give us loopholes
they created a second exemption the
estate tax exemption
is up there the million this is a second
exemption
for generation skipping tax computed
separately
they said out of this 50 that's left
we'll let you send the first million and
a half
per parent down to the grandkids and we
won't hit you with the second tax
anything over that 75 right away
people look at this and say bob we don't
know if we have them all yet
i'm not sure i want to send that amount
of money down to the grandkids anyway
the kids may need it this doesn't do us
any good
i don't want to send money down to the
grandchildren right away
and that's where
the generation skipping trust comes in
it's a trust for the benefit of
the child or children one each
you take the exemption and you split it
up
so they the children share it
it's irrevocable lasts for their
lifetime
it gets funded partly from the bypass
trust
partly from the q-tip trust
and partly from the survivor's trust to
the maximum we can stuff in there
round numbers three million dollars
and then it looks a lot like a bypass
trust because
the child is the trustee when they're
old enough to do it
the child can invade the income and the
principle for
their own health maintenance support and
education
and when the child dies they have a
special power of appointment that allows
them to control where the property goes
at their death just like the spouse
could
with the bypass trust so if their
children
the grandchildren are problems
they can tie it up in a different way
than grandma and grandpa originally
designed
it's a bypass trust for the child
a couple of benefits first one is it's
pretty well protected from creditors
so if they get into financial difficulty
they've got a pot to go back to
this money is accessible this is what
they got out right
this money the creditors have a harder
time getting into
it's also not part of the marital
property
if the marriage dissolves this isn't
part of the marital settlement
it's separate and off the board it's a
pot a starting point for them
and the reason tax attorneys love it
when the child dies
just as the bypass trust was free of
estate tax when the spouse died
the gst trust is free of estate tax
when the child dies including anything
it's grown to
and it passes down to the grandchildren
and doesn't get hammered by the 50
estate tax
so i look at this and i say what's the
burden well the child has to keep a
separate
account and they have to file a tax
return for the trust every year
same thing you have to do with a bypass
trust it's not a big burden we all have
ira accounts or whatever
and once the return gets started it's
pretty straightforward
bottom line is you've got three million
dollars
which hopefully they're not touching
letting grow because it's just a reserve
fund but they can touch it if they need
it
and it passes down free of estate tax
including all the accumulations
over their generation down to the next
generation free attacks
one and a half from each spouse yeah
so uh the
the gist of it is you can take the first
spouse's one and a half
we can designate it that ultimately
flows down including growth
so it might be a whole lot more than
three million because if this thing
grows during the survivor's lifetime
all that can flow in here could be a
whole lot bigger
and the end result is an estate planning
device for the family that allows you to
pass this stuff down
off the estate tax table
if these people exist before
the grandparents die you can play the
game
for another generation
and so these trusts flow into
generation skipping trust for the
grandchildren
don't get distributed until the
grandchildren die don't get taxed again
until the great
grandchildren die you can get
120 years of estate tax freedom for this
pot
there are things called dynasty trusts
which in
appropriate states this can go on
forever
california doesn't allow them to go on
forever but you can set up trust in
other states but the gist of it is
taking it off writing trust where the
family each generation has basically
full control
but it's just not subject to estate tax
why not
some people say well how much
flexibility do the kids have
can they buy a house that's for sure you
can buy a house with the assets you can
hold title in the trust
they have a right to reside in any
property held by the trust we
typically tell them don't do that though
because when they sell
the trust is not eligible for the five
hundred thousand dollar
capital gain exclusion on sales houses
that's only for individuals
so what you do is you use this as your
mortgage lender
you lend the money to the child they buy
it in their own name
and they pay the interest and principal
payments back to the trust
and they pay a really high rate of
interest
because they don't consider themselves
credit worthy
and
the interest is deductible and goes into
a pot that is going to be free of estate
tax
it's the closest thing i can get to a
deductible gift
and so the flexibility is there it's a
pot under their control it's the
equivalent of an outright gift
it's just not subject to estate tax
and that is really your basic
estate plan this is the kind of thing
you
design in and it's sort of it isn't a
matter of how large the estate if it's a
100 million dollar estate
i can only still only stuff maybe 3
million in here you still got a 97
million dollar
problem but the fact that it's a four
million dollar estate we can probably
hide everything
for the next generation because we can
stuff it all inside the gst trust
and you're outside of the estate tax
system so
the the only issue is well gee if we if
we're so small in a state that we don't
have an estate tax anyway bob why do
this
you shouldn't you know a pain to run
trust and so forth
if you don't have an estate tax you
don't go through all this planning
this does not control
one set of assets
the trust controls everything that's in
the trust
but life insurance
controlled by the beneficiary
designation
qualified plans controlled by the
beneficiary designation
you want to make sure you coordinate
those with your plan
this is where a lot of times people drop
the ball uh it's a pain
follow-up is is awful you make sure the
life insurance is payable to the trust
it flows in it's just part of the assets
and gets distributed according to your
plan
simple and every time you change your
you don't have to change the beneficiary
designation because it's all flowing
into the trust
qualified plans are different
they have a special income tax rule
that says if the distribution goes to a
spouse
as a lump sum the spouse can roll that
over into a rollover ira
and defer the income tax until they're
forced to take it out at 70 and a half
so you typically want to name the spouse
as the primary beneficiary in order to
do the rollover
but then you name this trust as the
contingent beneficiary
so it flows into your plan and goes
where you want it to go into trust for
the children
or not sometimes people will name
adult children here because children can
elect
a state status for the ira and spread
the income tax over their lifetime
what i find most of the time is they
take it
they don't extend it i want the money
now thank you so
going into the trust is simple easy but
be aware if you don't do these two
this can be a big part of the plan got a
lot of people with huge
rolled over 401k plans into rollover
iras
and that's a significant percentage of
the estate and nobody's looked at the
beneficiary designation
it still says prior spouse you know
current spouse says i don't think that's
where we want it to go
um so you've got to look at that as part
of the plan
three other documents you want to have
first is what's called the durable power
of attorney for property
the revocable trust works on anything
inside the trust
the will deals with property outside of
the trust if you die
what if it's outside of the trust and
you're just incompetent you're in the
coma from the auto accident
the power of attorney allows the
attorney in fact to deal with that asset
and you typically give them a power to
put it in the trust so you avoid probate
and you name the same person to be
attorney in fact as you've named as
executor
or trustee it's just a backup
to the trust to make sure everything
gets in it works
ninety-five percent of the time the five
percent is typically with insurance
companies
the one we ran into spouses incompetent
hit his head on a rock at a ski resort
spouse said
the insurance company said we're liable
here's a check we'll pay
staff said fine i'll sign the release
insurance company said no you won't
we want a court order we don't trust
powers of attorney
we want to know we don't know anybody
else once we get this thing done
so we had to go to court and that's
where the nomination
of conservator comes in that's the court
appointed person
for an incompetent just like an executor
but it's a pain to get
and expensive so you want to try to
avoid it as much as possible
it's uh it's like ten thousand dollars
just to get the things set up and then
you've got to do accountings every year
it's terrible
but you have it because it's a last
resort
last item advance
healthcare directive the pull the plug
document
not related to your property but to your
health care
who's going to make health care
decisions for you it's very often not
the same people
who are good financial managers much
more intimate kind of decision
often different for each spouse
if you have a health care document
that's more than two years old i would
recommend going in and getting it
updated it's not critical but they
passed something called hipaa
health insurance portability act they
terrified the medical community
they told him there was a fifty thousand
dollar fine and a year in jail
if you released medical information
without written consent
and then they said written consent means
this
typical overwriting the old
health care documents didn't necessarily
refer to hipaa
the question was were they strong enough
to satisfy
the doctor or the hospital when you went
to them and said i'm the agent for
health care give me the data
and they say no way go give me a hipa
form
well anybody who's been in the hospital
has probably signed one of these hipaa
forms when you went in
if you've been there or to a doctor in
the last couple years what
what most attorneys are doing i think is
you don't see it in the cma forum but
we're putting in language that says
references hipaa and lays out in
words yes the agent has health care
authority under hipaa
and when you're arguing with the
insurance company about coverage you can
get the data from the doctor or the
hospital
to prove to them that they overchar
underpaid or
you got overcharged or something else
that's
your set of documents the poor overwill
and the revocable trust
the beneficiary designations durable
power of attorney
nomination of conservator advanced
healthcare directive
you set it up with a bypass maybe a
q-tip
a gst maybe separate share and you're in
business
you've got the basic estate